welcome to rochefort district council's
remote meeting of the licensing and
appeals subcommittee
and welcome to anybody watching this be
a live stream
good afternoon my name is councillor
phil shaw and i am the chairman of the
licensing and appeals subcommittee
the other members
of the committee are if they could
introduce themselves
um councillor joe macpherson chairman
councillor chairman thank you and the
committee's legal advisor is miss angela
law
before we start can anybody please make
sure they restock their mobile phones
the purpose of today's hearing is to
consider an application for a temporary
events notice by mr j
ventum
of calls down limited in respect of a
site known as crouch valley showground
rally
please could the applicant or the
representative introduce themselves
if i may uh the applicant is no uh is
not here and we've not had uh received a
formal
um notice or withdrawal for the
application um therefore this hearing
must go ahead as we need to determine
the application itself
right thank you
right could
please could the council's licensing
officer introduce themselves
good afternoon i'm stephen greener i'm
the principal licensing officer
thank you have you any witnesses you
wish to call
no i don't have any witnesses thank you
thank you
could the responsible authority
introduce themselves
afternoon my name is kaley drain and i'm
the licensed officer from essex police
and i cover south end and rockford
thank you
good afternoon
sorry
good afternoon i'm ronald mcmanus also
from essex police on the senior
licensing officer covering the whole of
essex
thank you
uh i have you any witnesses you wish to
call
no thank you i thank you
have all the parties received the agenda
and reports for today's hearing
yes right the committee will follow the
procedure set out in paragraph note
item three of the agenda
will all parties know that they have 15
minutes to present their case
please could mr greener summarize the
application
good afternoon this is a report in
relation to an application under section
100 of the licensing act
on the 22nd of november 2021 the
temporary event notice was received via
the government digital service portal
from mr j venton from coolsdown limited
in wishim bishops in essex
and appendix a is a copy of the
application form
the notice is for an event to be held at
crouch valley show ground in rayleigh
essex on the 11th of december 2021
between
12 30 hours and 23 59 hours
the license ball activities are for the
sale of alcohol
the provision of regulate entertainment
and the maximum number of people
attending the event would be set at 300.
the venue does not hold a premises
license and no conditions can be
attached or applied to this application
the application was sent to essex police
and richard district council's
environmental health team on the 22nd of
november 2021 for consultation with a
deadline set of the 25th of november
2021 for representations
the application was reviewed by rocha
district council's environmental health
team which have not made any
representations against this application
an objection notice was received
from the chief of police on the grounds
that the use of the premises in
accordance with the temporary event
notice would undermine the public
nuisance and the public safety objective
of the licensing act of 2003.
a copy of the objection notice is
attached as appendix b
all parties involved have been served
with the relevant notices and
documentation required by paragraph 67
of the licensing act 2003 hearings
regulations of 2005.
the notices and documentation included
an explanation of their rights of person
to attend a hearing and to be
represented to give evidence and to call
witnesses
subsequently of not attending the
procedure to be followed at a hearing
and for applicants only a copy of all
the relevant representations that have
been made
it is proposed that the subcommittee
resolves
one of two options one to determine
whether the event should would undermine
the licensing objective of public
nuisance and public safety and serve a
counter notice stating the reasons for
that decision or two to allow the
license ball activities to go ahead as
stated in the notice and that is the end
of the report
thank you i have uh any members of the
subcommittee
any questions that you'd like to ask mr
greener
chairman
this week
yes
thank you if you don't mind me raising
my hand it's just it's easier than
meaning yes
um
first one please mr greener um
it's on a question of accuracy of the
form
if the form is inaccurate accurate
should it be um
still before us or refused
uh is this
the application was submitted
electronically and we
are can only base the information on the
application that was received at the
time
um
however if there is any errors that are
will uh
knowingly um incorrect it does say on
the declaration on um
page 4.10 is that the information
contained in this form is correct to the
best of my knowledge and belief i
understand it is an offence
to knowingly or recklessly make a full
statement in connection with the
temporary event notice so if there is
false information in the application
form
then
there is a offence that could be
committed and we would need to
investigate that further
thank you that leads me on then to a
couple of questions um 4.21
uh page 4.21 sorry um it says will you
be using rockford council land
the answer is yes
yes in relation to the other
documentation from page
418 onwards is the event management plan
um that was completed by the applicant
um where they've actually ticked yes
that should actually be no because
perhaps valley showground isn't our
ground but it is not part of the
official application um in relation to
the temporary event notice that
concludes and finishes at 4.11.
okay thank you
sorry thank you mr green um another
question um as the applicant isn't here
so perhaps i can just ask your opinion
on it
um
4.19 it asks the applicant to describe
the event
um now it says the wind wonderland
the only way is garage public event with
plenty of food drink and some regulated
music there will be some games for
children and parents alike such as crazy
golf and a photo booth
snow santa and slay on site too
above that it clearly indicates the
target audience category and under 18s
are ticked
yeah you agree with that
um then on
page
4.20 4.2
there is the adverb
for
and i just draw your
attention to the last paragraph above
the address
and the very last statement says
chairman i believe councilman mcpherson
is
frozen isn't she
thinks he's gonna come back in
i think what uh i'm trying to
[Music]
kevin you're happy for me to wait until
she returns yes um i think um
council shaw's family to find out so
she's trying to get back in i was
i think what she was going to say is
that on the so i'm trying to find it
that there will be no children allowed
chip chairman councilman mcpherson's
backing all right okay
you can see here on there sorry uh
i did hear the question it was in
relation to uh
4.20 which stipulates in the actual
poster it says strictly over 18s only
but on the previous page
which is 4.19 it talks about that there
will be
games for children parents and alike and
crazy golf
and it takes the um under 18s as the
target audience yes um i can confirm
this was the post that was attached to
the application at the time um i have
been sent an updated poster
which has been sent to me and also been
circulated to essex police as well
which is headed winter wonderland
um
and it has no mentions around um
no under 18s and it does say five pounds
per child
uh on the updated poster that we've had
um since the original application
i think very completely cute very
confusing i've got a couple of others is
that okay chairman yes
hopefully um
i won't get booted out again um
4.50
um rv points um rendezvous points in the
case of emergencies aren't they
yes that's correct could you explain um
uh how many he says there's three
recommended
how many is the
um organizer suggesting and are v points
not meant to be accessible
to emergency vehicles
yes uh this is a template that we have
created to help work out with rv points
um the
says that the primary rv point for staff
and public will be via the back exit of
the infrastructure side
and the backup location says um the
entrance gate is 10 meters wide traffic
marshals are at the gate all night
prevented traffic buildups emergency
services will be able to arrive on site
and to keep this clear i can only
comment on what's within the plan i'm
afraid
okay is that uh all uh
councilman person
looks like she's frozen again i'm afraid
chairman i've got a question for mr
greener please okay
so i was like hello mr i don't know if
you can actually answer this um because
i thought i was gonna ask the applicant
but i don't know if you've got any
amended
uh correspondence coming um on 4.24 is
um
he's they've ticked box about the
parking marshals it's one to five
now i just wondered if i could get we
could get clarification
how many they were actually going to get
but i don't think you'll be able to
answer that will you it would be the
applicant wouldn't it it would i'm
afraid i don't have that information
right thank you very much i haven't got
any further questions uh chairman
oh thank you
right i think um
seeing that joe is frozen now um
i think we'll move on to the responsible
authority if they could um submit their
submission please
chair joe's back right
i do apologize chairman um he's been
working absolutely fine for the last
hour convening um
i did have one last question and it was
in relation to unless somebody's asked
it about the dbs checks
no nobody has no sir okay um
mr green now 4.43
yes
i think it's a one two three four
fifth paragraph down
do the um security staff have a dbs
check the answer is not applicable or
that's what i believe n a means
again um i can only go by information
that has been given to myself is that um
when we ask them to complete an event
management plan we obviously provide
them with a template for them to use and
to guide them in the key sort of
questions and key points that
are highlighted it mentions here that
under lost children and vulnerable
persons it says who'll be allocated the
role of managing lost children and it
says be secured which is their security
team
then it asks do they have a dbs
certificate if so what is their
certificate number and it's put not
applicable so clearly
we're not able to determine as to
whether a member of the security team
has gotten enhanced dbs as they haven't
listed the certificate number on the
application form so we won't know if
they're suitable for looking after
children no we don't sorry thank you
thank you
right
um
move on then um
to the responsible authority
good afternoon um
i hope you have had a chance to read our
objection letter i will cover all the
points anyway
um
so start with this is the third ten
we've received for an event on this day
at this location by the same event
organizer
um as has been mentioned already the
event is described by the applicant as a
winter wonderland public event with food
drink and some regulated music
there'll be some games for children and
parents alike such as crazy golf splat
the rat etc um the event is to run from
12 30 pm until midnight for a maximum of
300 people
the previous 210s submitted for this
event essex police also objected to and
subsequently were withdrawn by the
applicant
although i would like to point out that
the previous tens that were applied for
were not for an all-day family event but
for an evening event
aimed
more towards alcohol and garage music
however our primary concerns have
remained the same throughout that is our
opinion that the location is not
suitable for this type of event in
winter months
the site entrance is located of the
a1245
which is a dual carriageway that
operates at the national speed limit of
70 miles per hour
there's no pedestrian access to the site
so any attendees will have to arrive and
leave by car as there is no public
transport that services this location
despite our requests we have not
received any information from the
organizer regarding the condition of the
site
such as if the car parking area and the
road areas are concrete or graveled um
or if the vehicles will actually be
moving across the field itself
if the weather conditions are poor on
the day or in the build up to the event
the site could be wet and muddy and this
could deter people from wanting to take
their vehicles onto the site
which could then mean
vehicles stopping on the dual
carriageway to try and pick people up um
or
the other side of that is if they do go
onto the site this could cause mud and
muck to be dragged onto the dual
carriageway as they exit which could
create a safety issue for other vehicles
and users of the road
essex police are aware that over the
years the site has hosted a number of
events that have required vehicle access
however none of those that we are aware
of have been in winter the applicant has
also not provided any details about what
action they will take in adverse weather
conditions such as those described
given the proposed nature of the event
and that it being an all-day event with
alcohol and djs the applicant has
indicated that customers will be advised
to pre-book taxis for the end of the
evening
i have previously discussed with the
applicant that nationally there is a
shortage of taxi drivers and this is
certainly an issue that is felt locally
our concerns are there if people
struggle to get collected quickly at the
end of the evening particularly in the
cold weather that they may try to walk
off site in order to find transport
elsewhere
as i've already mentioned there is no
footpath along the carriageway there is
no lighting around the entrance of the
site and pedestrians will be forced to
either walk along the grass bank or the
road itself
in the dark whilst possibly intoxicated
which causes a huge public safety risk
in the previous event management plans
the organizer did mention a shuttle bus
service they would run
however that was not included in this
application
although it appears that it is still
being advertised
when asked to provide more information
about the capacity frequency and the
locations as to where the shuttle bus
would go the organizer has not provided
that information to us
at my last check earlier today tickets
are still available to purchase for this
event however not for the event as we
have described the advertising on the
ticket website does not mention any
provisioning for children in fact it
states strictly over 18.
it is not winter wonderland but a winter
themed garage fest and it is still
advertised as running between 7 p.m and
2 2 a.m which is the original times on
the first submitted 10.
whilst our initial concerns remain the
same that we believe the site to be
unsuitable for this type of event and
that the organizer has provided
insufficient plans and information to
address our concerns
our key concern now is that the event
organizer intends to run this event not
in line with the application is set out
and we do not have confidence that the
organizer will therefore run an honest
safe and well planned event and for that
reason we believe the application should
be refused thank you
um
of the committee any questions they wish
to ask
am i allowed to ask any questions
no
no chairman just for clarification uh
councillor island gaston is only here
for observation
i wasn't uh
i wasn't going to allow her anyway so uh
council mcpherson
thank you chairman
um
i think that you've highlighted all the
public safety issues that um we had
discussed earlier on when we've read
through the paperwork
um
however
can i just say um ask
your opinion even if a shuttle bus
service was provided
this would this um be able to stop
people from still picking up dropping
off or would they still be allowed to do
that
um my understanding from
what i've read in in the previous
applications and event management plans
is that the shuttle bus service would be
in addition to
to people still obviously driving onto
the site dropping off picking up it
would just be an additional service that
they would run
thank you so it wouldn't um address any
of the public highway issues that you've
already highlighted to us such as the
weather conditions the mud on the roads
um the fact that this is um
in the winter months when it's dark in
the speed limit 70 miles an hour
thank you
thank you
our counselor sure of you any questions
you wish to ask
no thank you chairman why thank you
right um
well obviously the applicant isn't here
so we can't ask their submission
um so we therefore move to
closing statements uh
uh are there any closing statements
anybody wishes to make
no nobody's indicating
right chairman
um uh mr mcmanus is indicating all right
i can't i couldn't see okay
so i wasn't quick enough to get to the
button
um just to give you some um context um
this issue has arisen across the country
where events themselves have been run
fine
but it's the the people attending the
path of least resistance parking outside
not not being off-road
and then of course we have motors going
about their normal business at midnight
coming down into that round about with
potentially mud on the road people
walking in the road
cars potentially parked on the hard
shoulder especially if the the the
premises themselves in the field is
a bit muddy under underfoot
people will tend to take the path of
least resistance to get away
and those are the concerns that we've
tried to highlight to you this morning
and we've we've actually have evidence
of that in other parts of the county and
we would feel that this is also going to
happen on this occasion if this was to
go ahead thank you sir thank you
right the commission will now adjourn to
consider the case um we will return in
approximately
um
[Music]
chairman if i may um given that the
applicant isn't here
um i understand from mr greener that we
will be sending uh the
um determination through to them
um
and mr greener can contact
essex police of the decision
so therefore if you wish you could close
the um meeting here
okay i'll do that and then we'll make a
decision right
if is that okay with the essex police
are you happy with that we will contact
you with uh
yeah that's no problem at all thank you
why thank you
okay
okay it's any
we'll close them now and um
we'll uh make our decision right thank
you
thank you thank you